la cumbre de nieve ha sido la primera de
su tipo pero no será la última el
ministro de exteriores israelí yair
lapid anunció que el encuentro que
reunió a los cancilleres de estados
unidos-israel más grain emiratos árabes
unidos marruecos y egipto se convertirá
a partir de ahora en un foro regional
permanente además dijo que las puertas
están abiertas para todos incluidos los
palestinos que fueron excluidos del
encuentro en el desierto del sur israelí
los jefes diplomáticos se buscaron
mostrar unidad frente a iran una de las
metas del secretario de estado
estadounidense de antony blinken era
calmar a los aliados de washington en la
región frente a la posible reactivación
del acuerdo nuclear con teherán blinken
también reivindicó los acuerdos de
abraham firmados en 2020 bajo la
presidencia de donald trump que
permitieron la normalización de
relaciones entre israel y bahrain
emiratos árabes unidos y posteriormente
marruecos destacó que los pactos se le
permiten progresos en áreas como la
economía y la tecnología aunque no
sustituyen la necesidad de avanzar en un
proceso de pases con los palestinos los
representantes de las naciones árabes
reiteraron su compromiso con una
solución al conflicto que permita la
creación de un estado palestino con
capital en jerusalén
pero para el primer ministro palestino
mohamed está bien la cumbre es una
ilusión y una recompensa de las naciones
árabes a israel el otro punto común de
la declaración conjunta que hizo
hincapié en la coexistencia pacífica y
en la necesidad de crear otra narrativa
para la región fue la condena al ataque
terrorista ocurrido el domingo en la
noche en la ciudad israelí de hadera
allí dos hombres abrieron fuego y
causaron la muerte de dos policías de
fronteras posteriormente fueron abatidos
por las fuerzas de seguridad un hecho
que en palabras de los seis diplomáticos
se da aún más relevancia a una cumbre
que como expresó blink en hace unos años
era imposible